I'm going up I'm going up
he just kissed me
he just intercepted
part one bar one
[Music]
so this is one of our most important
news topics that we always need to
consistently bring to the viewers out
there
another climate activist gluing
themselves to something come on don't be
don't be too disappointed this one kind
of made sense all right better what did
you just say because right when you
talked I crunched and it was really loud
thank you
you speak around his crunches yeah go
ahead say it one more time be a better
host okay basically what I said was be
fast
but it was great so it's not I throw up
I was just saying that this was one of
those climate activists that glued
themselves into something but it kind of
made sense
correct me if I'm wrong
well when they glue themselves to like
the front glass of art at museums
I don't fully get it no irony
you want irony right oh is that what
you're looking for I get it yeah this
one right here okay these climate
activists glued themselves to a Runway
at a Berlin airport forcing officials to
divert over a dozen flights affecting
nearly six thousand I still don't get it
I get it because air airplanes are
contributing to Greenhouse glasses and
but it's like directly correlated
instead of like a Picasso he hates it I
kind of don't believe it dude I kind of
don't believe it okay
no I just from a person that doesn't
understand any of this stuff I just go I
protest well is the point of them gluing
themselves to stuff to get attention
yeah yeah so that gets attention yeah
but they're never gonna stop it dude
this is my thing they're never gonna
stop it well I wonder if you do this in
like Iran or something what would happen
they should do it in China bro
glue themselves China's like the
heaviest contributor to [__]
greenhouse gases but of course we can't
do [__] about that yeah go talk to those
guys yeah go talk to them what are we
celebrating our [__] 50th yulin
Festival
no they're not [__] stopping any of
that [__] yeah dude
so they um the activist group I think
last generation is what they're called
morbid
um denounced air travel as quote not a
means of Transport for normal citizens
one affluent percent of the population
is responsible for around half a flight
related greenhouse gas emissions so are
you grounding commercial flights then
bro are you is this private are you
[__] disrupting DiCaprio's plane but
that's the question yeah like or just
nice people we're trying to get home for
Thanksgiving people on Southwest and
[__] that's a huge question they should
ask themselves like what if they glue
themselves and then they [__] [__] up
DiCaprio's playing it's like dude that
guy's going to save the planet on his
private jet and he's gonna make great
movies is having a meeting with like
some [__] Italian Prime Minister
saving the planet is it is that what he
does yeah he goes and gives speeches
about this [__] all over yeah and they
talk about Summits that's what a summit
is bro it's like [__] Twitter it's
like oh I'm giving a speech I'm saving
the [__] Earth right now dude and no
one cares or does anything everyone just
jerks off to the speech yeah I'm gonna
[__] with leosa way of doing [__] I like
him I think he's a great actor I like
him yeah if he gives me advice on acting
or something like that or like has
something cool to talk about acting I'm
gonna listen bro what do you mean
clean water some [__] oh Leo oh dude
that's too broad I thought you had a
specific thing he does like is that no
he's a he he is a big he's like global
warming like like super scared of all
that [__] while he's on his beach house
property what 25 year olds it's like
Obama Obama I think that's irregardless
I don't think it's necessarily
hypocritical from a guy like him I think
that if you what's not hypocritical
nobody just wants to hear it though
what's the power bill on his home that
has two people in it and and Al Gore two
Al Gore too bro Al Gore lives in a
[__] estate now on the beach yeah
huge estate
and saying that we're gonna be covered
in Ocean in the next 20 years if he
believed that that's yeah maybe from the
sprinkler system that doesn't turn off
doesn't everything eventually like get
covered up in Ocean anyway like over
time yeah right natural selection yeah
dude natural selection maybe all I'm
saying is you live in a [__] you live
in a tiny home and then do a summit you
tell me about it from a tiny home and
I'm more down I really am 100 and I
don't I actually don't think that
hypocrisy is like you know necessarily
the worst thing because everyone's a
hypocrite right but I just think you're
more of a spokesperson if you're living
the life yeah that's what I think yeah
like the Patagonia billionaire you
[__] gave away his company to his own
people but he still
a little bit better than other
billionaires that don't do that he can
talk way more about it yeah I think the
funniest farce is people not seeing that
taking a climate solution is just
another allocation of money in a
different direction that's it
support us and give us your money
because the other argument is like okay
the guys that are like hey buy from
local business and Farmers but you're
also
um price gouging your community because
you can't scale at the rate of these
bigger companies who can give better
prices to the community and is the
message bad so like here's my whole take
right like take Jeff Bezos and have Jeff
Bezos stand on a soapbox and say we
should support small businesses right
that's stupid it's stupid because it's
like well you're not you're [__]
killing these guys but you're saying the
right thing so like I get it like
hypocrisy shouldn't like muddy the
message but it does when you're standing
there being that person and then
evangelizing yeah that's like you're
going on a world tour in a diesel truck
talking about [__] CO2 emissions
because that's exactly what they're
doing with their [__] private jets to
one conversation to another just to have
a conversation yeah they need to go a
horse and carriage dude that's the sad
thing is like these are all like actual
real things happening but the commercial
response to it is not correct I don't
think how so because there's too much
monetization for something where versus
actual solution oh yeah it's all a
racket it's like hey before we propose
anything we can actually do about it
here's some things you can buy that's in
the direction of fixing it get a Tesla
mostly powered by coal right it's just a
commercial for another product it's not
necessarily like fixing a problem and
the consumer is like oh I feel better
because I'm doing my part because like
we've already like talked about this a
ton but we I mean by now we already
recognize a lot of the solution to these
problems don't lie in the Every Man's
decision making it's not the common
person's changing their own lifestyle
it's more these big giant [__] guys
changing what the [__] they're doing
with their billions of dollars no no
we're not talking about that we want to
get ad deals
the blue collars should turn their
[__] ACS off that's what I think
have 30 second showers yeah that's what
I think stop flushing your toilets
if it's yellow let it mellow am I right
yeah you know Oprah's doing that right
with her [__] 40 bedroom home you
know that's why the [__] straws thing
was probably the perfect example oh I
[__] hate it it's like oh let's get
everyone's attention on [__] straws
but we could still have you know [__]
gigantic oil spills that don't get
cleaned up it's like no straws like when
they're talking about droughts in
California and you're like talk to the
[__] golf courses dude
we need the golf courses hey isn't it we
want good greens this is JK group think
bro sorry hey sorry guys okay you're
attacking the big guys who are actually
doing you know what dude I love golf
courses and I love what they do for the
droughts in California that's what I
think that's what I'm talking about
that's a Nick done take I just I just
love it it's such a dead giveaway once
you see people strongly monetizing guilt
I feel it oh brother that's the first
red flag it's like huh once you start
hearing sir McLaughlin it's good
marketing
it works Sarah McLachlan worth so does
anybody disagree with this takers it's
just JK we're all just uh we're steam
we're Echo chambering yeah we're Echo
chamber and um
Leo is awesome I like
anything so just you know
I think celebrities can't do anything
but environmental because they can't do
anything political because if they do
well [__] that's a pretty big one but so
many celebrities don't do a lot of
environmental stuff that's why I think
uh when Leo did like what was the movie
called
oh Basketball Diaries Basketball Diaries
don't look good basketball well they end
up doing environmental like all of their
like things that they do push it ends up
being environmental because it's the
safest one did anybody see the movie
don't look up yeah no is it good I think
it's really good so I I think it was a
great satire on him like the perspective
even even us conversating about this
right now is is it talks about saving
water bottles and [__]
he laughs about those things I think the
fact that people laugh about it the fact
that like when you uh when you have
impending doom at your doorstep and then
you tell people who are supposed to be
empowered to do things they're like haha
dude nobody's going to change their mind
anyway and then it's just like an actual
way the world thinks therefore things
never change yeah but also which is
exactly kind of what when you've been
ringing the Doomsday Bell for 50 years
and like you can I can point to articles
and stuff about oh by the by the year
2000 we won't have glaciers anymore and
all this [__] and that doesn't pan out
yeah people have more question marks
like than ever they just do because
oftentimes their models just don't tend
to pan out with the timeline that they
give you so then it actually discounts
what their messaging is which I agree
with ultimately if you want to like like
you know do something about greenhouse
gases it's time to make the switch to
nuclear but nobody wants to do that no
yeah nobody wants to do that but that's
the only thing because if you really
think we're it's at that scale yeah
we're [__] we're eight years away you
cannot reverse the effects past this
point well guess what dude you you have
to do radical things like to switch to
nuclear but nobody wants to but what
they want to do is stop Korean barbecues
from having gas grills you know that
like that they're trying to do that in
L.A yeah they are yeah a 20 30 right no
plastic bags no plastic bags but see
that's what I'm saying so you want to
you want to come down to all of us and
tell us how important and dire the
situation is in your solution ban straws
yeah like honestly like that's where
we're at is that a real solution is that
really gonna be it helps a little bit
yeah exactly feel good [__] it helps
it's wearing a [__] I'm wearing a
ribbon at an awards ceremony to raise
awareness for this thing we should wear
more ribbons it's just so perfectly in
line with the social Guild climate
that's like we're sitting in right now
yeah so it's such an easy thing to
weaponize Guild is fun though it's easy
it's easy yeah and and plus like putting
that guilt out there like the people do
the work for you you don't have to keep
like marketing it it's like you just put
it out there oh check out this video
about [__] turtle with a straw on its
nose and you just release it and it's
like that's it it's like everyone else
dude the polar bear on the glacier video
right yeah like all that [__] works
really well because you're like oh my
God this is the last Glacier and the
polar bear stuck on it [__] all these
SUV drivers right but it's like like you
when you watch the clip it's like this
Glacier like like this part of this
glitch is [__] huge over here but
like there's this little polar bears
like who swam over here and he's just
chilling over here yeah he's a swimmer
and we're gonna take their word for it
because we don't know we don't know what
they're saying they're painting the
picture of what's happening in this
polar bear yeah if they're captioning
they're they're coming with the
thumbnail title we all know how [__]
important that is to pull eyeballs and
like that's what works hey dude Coney
2012.
that polar bear doesn't even have a
Coca-Cola in his hands so there's not a
real polar bear so sad he's looking for
a baby seals to eat so Nick you're
officially uh saying you're a climate
change designer yep yeah I love it
I'm sure he doesn't believe I'm a
climate change supporter I'm a climate
change activist denier